foreign
[Music]
[Music]
now who's ready for other people
he's everybody's favorite give it up for
your house
[Music]
let's party let's watch some people [ __ ]
tonight
it's good to be here my name is Hans I
hope you're a dating expert slash Guru
I've been on over 25 days
so we're all gonna have a fun time uh
sign up you can always sign up there's
one lgbtqia plus person come on now
we're more Progressive than that someone
come out of the closet just for the show
okay for the show uh but yeah we're
gonna have a fun time this is a great
little live stream show so if you don't
want your last name set on the podcast
or you want to withhold information
make sure to do that
[Music]
it's always good to start a show with
the disclaimer danger ahead you might
get dogs
but uh no it's very rarely happened uh
it only happened once so far and it's
not really a big deal that we really
should focus on uh it's already tending
in the courts but uh yeah we're gonna
have a fun time we have a guest tonight
uh a very funny man from New York City
uh you might have seen him on any of the
number of things he's been on very very
funny man today's gonna have for Ian
finance a human being
thank you
the video he is white ass thank you so
much for coming here tonight you brought
your own ashtray yes I'll be smoking up
here it'll be like your dad supervising
you on your dates yes with the shotgun
maybe everybody's dad and for the LGBT
I'll be everyone's Daddy
I have the LGBT member here I think oh
hell yeah yeah maybe you could go on a
date with Ian if you're in the bucket if
you sign up why is everyone leaving
do you uh famously have told the story
about uh transgender uh incident that
you you were in which one uh which one
um the second one the one where I got
robbed or what yeah
I don't remember specifically which one
but I know like that's something that
you do like that's I love it you're like
it's something that you do you live in
sin
no I uh I've been with I've dated trans
women deal with prostitutes anyone here
ever be been with a prostitute or a sex
worker oh I'm the only one I'm the only
one that supports women
small local business [ __ ] you guys a
very Christian addition of other people
dating show this is uh yeah yeah Sunday
service of the uh this young life group
meeting
but uh thank you guys for coming we're
gonna go ahead and pick a couple names
out of the bucket let's see what happens
the first game out of the straight man
bucket is a man named Charlie
hey here it comes from the back
I don't know how
to the way the show works is that they
go on a date for one minute and then
afterwards we interview them okay so
Denise is the straight woman coming up
[Applause]
purple
we watch this dance for one minute to
this
he's already tripping head over heels in
Charlotte Good Luck Charlie Charlie
yes
wow Charlie all right
eating Buller chair out already but
that's fine starting now
yeah I'm not very common on that side
um Denise you started with right yes how
you doing today
fantastic how are you I'm good A little
score
too much adultery too much
[Music]
happy Sunday yeah happy Sunday
yeah
I was expecting to go on a date later
but
okay what do you like to do in your free
time
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
Autism Speaks but barely come on it was
like watching Charlie on an interview
with his probation officer
Charlie have you been arrested before
time I knew it I knew it I knew it it
was a cargo shorts
a lot of places to put your stolen
merchandise Charlie he's turned out by
asking uh or saying that you were sore
from adultery is that
yeah no no what's like adulting to you
a lot of sex oh
it's gonna throw that out there yeah
when a man comes on a date with you and
he says he's sore from too much butt sex
uh
affectionate it's really nice Sir
Charles
all the way up
if Charlie could come up and and like
approach differently would you give them
a chance
like what can Charlie learn from this
[Music]
thing yeah keep not getting laid
so what do you mean by sore from
adultery what did you mean to say
like adulting
oh classic error
um but yeah that's cool
um Denise you're looking for someone
who's affectionate is there are there
any more requirements or are you just
looking for a dog
I could use another dog I think you
already have a dog start barking Charlie
I can't do pets oh Charlie it was a
perfect chance to go I could do doggy
style
good work Charlie's already crossed your
home off from the list of places you can
burglarize underwear
you have a dog Denise have you ever been
arrested before no I'm not oh yeah
that's good Opposites Attract yeah
that's nice
I can help you you know get a new car if
you're ever getting a car wrecked yeah
Charlie you look like a guy who knows
his way around a catalytic converter
I've I've had my hands on us
[Music]
that's a New York uh calling card right
there I was bonded over left
so Charlie uh What uh what brings you
out tonight what uh what are you looking
for another day because I've noticed you
already came here with a date and now
you're on another day wow no wonder you
said adultery
is on the blind you know there's
sometimes when you're in a relationship
there's a moment where you gotta open up
to the person but you know the time is
not right in the place is not right say
just go see another woman
yeah I mean here is like we can open our
relationship more
yeah why communicate when you can just
do it
just [ __ ] around until all your problems
are solved
excuse them to a podcast about that
what's that I just listened to a podcast
about that yeah and then the murder
mystery yeah latest episode of cereal
uh so wait you're here with someone yeah
I'm here with my lady
what we're just here for oh okay are you
guys really looking for a third no not
that I know of them is there anything
you want to tell us
did you guys meet on love after lockup
laughs
would you ever join a couple Denise
I think so but you didn't say no
and door is still
Apartments
yeah he said affectionate not available
what if he's married but he loves
holding hands
yeah I meant that oh wow
that's a Texas three-way right there
yeah I I would like to see Charlie and
his girlfriend going to date up here
yeah everyone's just seeing Charlie and
his girlfriend
get her up there what's her name again
Mia would you like to come up here and
go on a date with your boyfriend Mia hop
on up here
foreign
hi yeah
[Music]
okay
um
so we're not looking for it there we go
do you want that I don't need that yeah
[Music]
is that time
Charlie's heard that one a lot
all right
[Music]
any questions
thank you anytime Mia and Charlie
Charlie are you not used to not having a
translator with your girlfriend
this was the worst episode of 90 Day
Fiance
she speaks better yeah I hope you guys
are more convincing to the Customs agent
that you can get your green card oh
God
you know how did you guys meet
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that's cool so that's something you guys
have in common what else do you guys
ever coming
um a lot actually surprisingly like
we both like to smoke a lot of weed
unique yeah me a little bit more
yeah you can't find that anywhere else
I'll use that space so how are you
feeling and then Mia you said hi which I
don't know if it yours speak Japanese or
if you're just like hello or if you're
saying you were high on drugs I'm high
on Wheaton you're high on freedom yeah
it's not weed it's not legal there yet
no not yet I mean it's not legal here
yet either oh yeah oh yes yes
wait wow you're something going on in
course yeah wow that's a Twist that's a
that's something no yes you have nothing
on chords that's that's how you guys I
found it over priors over bonds
you guys both have the same command over
the English language you because you're
not from here Charlie because he's got
PTSD
uh Charlie what is uh like the craziest
thing that you guys done together since
you've been together for three weeks
um
I mean we were in La for like 10 days
that week you know we want to like take
the Hollywood Sign so three weeks in you
guys went on vacation together for 10
days yeah it's like a third of your
relationship and you survived it yeah it
was dope it was except for the [ __ ]
traffic in the airport yeah
yo I really admire that just meeting
someone and being like [ __ ] it let's go
to La yeah
I I'm Chinese I have money
oh all right this is very much
oh okay Charlie you're the man dude
I probably figured out the key
wow are you aren't you afraid that he's
gonna try to con you and steal your
money are you do you think that's okay
it's okay we have more
oh my God it's like an episode of bad
vegan
I love it this is great so what's like
an ideal date night for you guys you
guys just go to the one of many the
ghost Departments of your family no yeah
actually that's what we're saying you
know really yeah give it up for your
future landlord yeah all right landlord
overboard
someone would probably saved in my bones
department so wait your family owns a
ton of high-end real estate and they
just yeah
that's why I'm in Austin because she's
rich and she has something like money
and then she has houses here and what do
you do for work I go to school
um and you Charlie I don't work I just
hang out and try to do comment yet man
and date up yeah yeah
oh yeah wow that's an American Dream
find the dangerous woman to finance your
degree so what's next where are you guys
gonna go on vacation next no no
so it's too much vacation yeah it was
like 21st century problem what uh what's
the most annoying thing that Charlie did
on vacation is he like chew with his
mouth open or no he doesn't talk with
when he's brushing his teeth I'm first
generation so I'm like I don't care
about stuff like that yeah you know we
sleep on the ground and [ __ ]
with your money buy a bed
it's not even stock
yeah okay well it's got weird
2020 saved my life that's cool yeah why
oh you bought stock yeah my dad oh we
didn't have a lot of money were you
studying in school English how to jog
the system oh okay sorry English
literature because
that's great you're studying English
literature and Charlie's learning how to
read yes
upon us
you're a comedian couple that met here
at the creek of the cave
hopefully they don't uh
talk about me and their Acts
if we mentioned in their acts I might be
scared
um but yeah that was a couple they
already know each other that was wild
that was I mean yeah I don't know who's
taking advantage of who yeah I think
it's an equal exchange so I think it's
okay yeah Patrick M
Patrick M coming up
and then the woman is Lindsay r
aisy
her friends are excited for her yeah
she's got the backing of her friends
here's Patrick doing the champion oh
nice say Uncle Ray that's nice
I think Patrick's already come
several times going on a day for one
minute starting now
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
entities are on this table right now
really what entities are there beings
here maybe are the shrooms still oh no
no no no that was yesterday
um
[Music]
well where are you from yeah do you want
to guess like Lithuanian or something
give it up for the Lithuanian Cochran
don't lift away you love her you want to
double the guess wow I've never seen a
brother sister on her first name before
this is amazing yeah you guys look like
you guys you go to the same LensCrafters
Lindsay looks like the camp counselor
the camp Patrick goes to
hey we're in Texas
test again oh yeah
so if you had more time what would you
have answered where are you from
um I'm from the audience
Sweden yeah so Lithuania is close
geographically language Wise It's
Different yeah cool and what's your
favorite thing to do in Sweden like if
if Lindsay went to Sweden with you what
would you do to like impress her or have
fun
and
go on a nice walk in Stockholm a very
beautiful city
yeah I've actually went to Sweden
I was really sick the whole time oh oh
yeah why did you have some basketball I
didn't have any mushrooms with her yeah
what stranger things the whole time the
first season this was this was a while
ago that's an expensive way to watch
stranger things
I must watch it in Swedish it's a good
memory you know yeah in Swedish we call
it a stranger things
um so there was some Swedish comedy
right there there's a McDonald's app
that I saw and the word said God snack
God sad and it made me laugh a lot wait
what it says Godsmack not sad
those goddess Europeans
I don't know what that means Godsmack
God sack I think
oh oh I know it's good to taste good
cause like probably 45 minutes
or something or something like that okay
yeah Bond means good
um
yeah exactly yeah okay
so you know wow this data is not going
God
foreign
I'm on a girl's trip with my best
friends from college none of us are
getting married we're just here for fun
that's great why don't you take a nice
Swedish boy out with you tonight I've
actually worn to like brown ethnic memes
oh God you couldn't have gone whiter
foreign
existence yeah I actually have some
Irish heritage as well so literally can
even worse
so so wait you only date roundups yes
have you ever dated a white guy
he sucks
[Music]
it wasn't Brown enough wow and how all
how bad are you at your parents
yeah
where are you from originally
Aurora Colorado Aurora Colorado were
there a lot of ground people there
yeah
like a uh like a house
are there any brown guys here you you're
interested in
yeah yeah that's that sounds that sounds
right hey if your bird put yourself out
get up here brownie come on she wants to
taste yeah
Patrick is about to go do blackface real
quick yeah
yeah I guess that's my only shots
no no that's my only shot to go and do
breakfast
yeah
I don't know what you do in Sweden but
over here we gotta get away from that
but not to
put you on the spot but uh what do you
think about asamen
[Music]
take it easy
I'm finding out if it's not white men or
just Batman
[Music]
but not yellow
and I'm going about your guidelines all
right
more do you what kiss the nation before
Albany what day one interesting
well you just just [ __ ] us and leave us
our hearts I've heard about you
foreign
oh brown guys was a girl wow are you
single Brown guy
I did raise my foot yeah you raised your
foot
oh and who's the girl with you
oh and you guys are single together
what kind of guys are you into
what color
what's your favorite color
okay I think she's a lesbian
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
holy [ __ ] you're going to Guatemala next
week there's a lot of friends and in the
interim you're homeless you really came
to the right place
there's some brown guys out there for
you
you can shack up in one of their tents
I dated one homeless person you did I
mean you looked in his van Jesus Christ
how is your [ __ ] the Statue of Liberty
I wasn't sure if he was using me for my
shower or yes it was
Patrick uh what how does this make you
feel good camping trips they must have
been Brown as [ __ ]
how does this make you feel are you um
are you interested in uh you know like
uh homeless people would you date a
homeless woman
um temporarily it's temporarily homeless
that could work
I know you take her home you got to sink
she's like whoa I'm impressed yeah I
feel like my skin is the wrong color but
my sink is
usable so
do you think it's Brown from all the
puke after you uh because you're hung
over all the time do you live here no
I'm uh visiting yeah
successful yeah Stockholm Sweden where
are you staying uh I'm also homeless no
oh my God what a match made in Hell
or Heaven
um I know airbn news yeah that's cool so
yeah you uh you she's homeless uh is
that that doesn't concern you but uh
wait till you find out our health care
situation
I mean
America's Health Care situation is
pretty would you ever date an American
uh I have you had yeah how was that yeah
pretty good honestly I'm not a military
at some point well area you're gonna
meet the person you're dating for the
first time
we met in Sweden and I'm gonna meet her
yet again oh she lives in Austin and she
lives in uh the most
a tourist family in the states of
Arkansas
wow so you're going you're coming from
here to Arkansas to be with her in the
meantime you want to get some little
awesome so I haven't actually done it's
uh on my list yeah um
so you're going to meet her yes that's
so nice yeah that's great good for you
that's cool did you know that Arkansas
is nowhere near Texas
last week
whoa look you had a tour guide right
next to you I actually hung out with
your girlfriend yeah
[Music]
what do you do for work Lindsay
well I was a mushroom farmer
I love it you're homeless you don't have
a job and you're like no I don't like
whites
I got standards I don't know I have a
job at the moment you should check out
how many how many homes uh whites have
they have a lot of homes yeah
yeah I just came from the whitest place
in America so where was I where was your
house there
um in the mountains in Colorado
that's cool in Colorado somewhere yeah
so you're moving to Guatemala to live
yes that's great what are you going to
do down there for work I'm gonna learn
Spanish
you're gonna get paid to learn Spanish
no I'm gonna pay you to do that so you
haven't learned Spanish yet I I know a
little bit but then how long have you
known that you were going to impressed
about it how long have you know you're
going to Guatemala
for sure for sure like a mom it's been a
dream of mine for a while
a lot of Viola what do you like about it
you ever just have a dream and you're
like I gotta go there yeah we're not
addicted to mushrooms
so it's been a dream of yours forever to
move to Guatemala but they do Guatemala
but you didn't do the light work of
learning Spanish first I I'm doing
Kinsler you know I know a little bit I I
can take a taxi there and you can just
watch another Netflix show Guatemala
we're gonna watch you on an episode of
Forensic Files
your friends are kicking in yeah they're
they're nice to you okay and none of
them are fighting enough to move with
you yeah yeah and they're just drop me
off in the middle of the Jungle remember
yourself Lindsay I shared my location
with them so do you know anyone down
there
foreign
[Music]
what is it about Guatemala that
intrigues you
besides the man
well I want to learn Spanish
schools that this is our affordability
it's very slow yes I'm very frugal oh so
you're going to school down there to
learn Spanish and then you work so you
make money saved up to to go there yes
oh and my plan is to travel around South
America and then Asia
kind of very big plan yeah
nice came here to Texas to get used to
the brown people
yeah if you want to meet at Guatemala
just go to the Border
I've been to Mexico a lot well I'm
always like a little more colorful
months and uh hourly how old am I yeah
oh do you think don't ask me that
sweetheart
oh I don't know like 24
26. okay cool
nice so you've always had a dream to
move to Guatemala and what's after
Guatemala what's the long-term here
[Music]
nice and what's your long-term plan like
what do you want to do
yeah
[Music]
I don't know I uh I work with video
games but I'm on a sabbatical I'm a
vision first okay like too much video
games I gotta have fun yeah you're on a
fishing Quest no I'm here too
no I'm here to do everything but it
means it's so comedy barbecue everything
else travels I've been traveling a lot
across the uh mostly yeah it makes sense
because uh America to Sweden is like
Guatemala to America
so we don't have health care anyways
um yeah you guys are great uh so what do
you think about uh the new uh you know
uh the the new dating scene in Austin
are you dating a lot here have either of
you hooked up since you've been down
here
play this person
I love you
no
[Music]
um
[Music]
no I I was I'm not dead yesterday and it
went pretty good oh nice are you gonna
see her again yeah I think so yeah oh
cool yeah so let's tell Arkansas about
her yeah yeah so being for me and your
girlfriend in Arkansas you're really
trying to throw it around we
um we're like friends because we she's
going to be there for four years because
she's like a doctor
so it's something to happen you know oh
yeah so we're dispense so Arkansas is
very Guatemala
I guess yeah
well thank you guys for going
a whole other couple coming up yeah
the last watching people dates and uh me
not having to do that you know they're
doing all the work we got Alex a man
coming up oh it's your guy yeah
[Applause]
coming up to meet another single woman
yeah uh she already went up
uh we got Emma everything coming up
Emma's father
like Guatemala table
going on a date with a Guatemalan
a brown man
and go
[Music]
you're starting
I'm starting Texas
it's good to see you thanks for visiting
me after I arrested you last night you
wrestled me I rested you you arrested me
yeah you were driving really fast
there's a no shot they don't let me
drive
I'm mad I'm not driving yeah
yeah
what you got out of my ticket how did
you I wasn't driving I was on mushrooms
but I arrested you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
give it up for Emma and Alex
what a beautiful couple that was the
worst Abbott and Costello I've ever seen
I forgot where we were what what are you
a cop yeah
no you're not I am right you're a police
officer police officer there you go I
don't see your badge yeah do I have it
yeah
my [ __ ] station is right there what
station y'all know where the boys
station
oh one two three main street
[Music]
yeah like this this has worked before he
doesn't just do this I don't know I I do
it from someone
[Music]
this crowd's not enjoying us at all
Alex you're about as good at reading
audiences as you are an improv
um
Alex how does that usually go do
why do you think he did that what is
going on with him
analytical I don't know
yeah no that's nice I'm waiting for the
punch no she was just being inquisitive
because you're the writer
um I'm the writer I thought you were I
thought you were trying to be like
sexual because you were like tell me
when you got out of the ticket I was
like Jesus put it back God damn it the
first date how about does everything
have to be Caliente with you people
he's from New York
it's a different kind of racism
it's an acceptable racism
Emma uh how's your day in life been I've
been a lot of First Dates recently
um kind of I like the first date I don't
like the second date today
should I call them victims
does it do you have teeth marks on your
leg what is that that's a burn oh it's a
burn that's a good burn I was loading a
generator into the back of a truck as we
all do from time to time
but I was doing it alone and I'm not
very strong well where was Lindsay in
your [ __ ] gag over the traveling
system
prevented
I know I thought Alex got you before you
got time
Alex is already writing a ticket for
that right now
someone Burns before me oh yeah he
didn't do anything
you didn't burn her
um Alex what wait Emma why were you
loading a generator are you like into
like uh you're like into a small tiny
home living in Colorado I run a food
truck with one of my annual gals in
Little Rock Arkansas nice what kind of
food we sell Crepes wow
[Music]
Alex uh what do you think about uh this
one is really hot what is it was hot
does this work usually I think I'm going
to take her home
you must be gay are you getting a little
bit
weird little shape-shifter
I'm not into you though until right now
we're gonna find out he's actually white
r come back up please
Alex what is your uh what is your normal
normal dating life look like do you date
a lot of gym Asians
skinny boys
black hair
dual sketch artists
they're just describing me
okay well it's not the fun thing where
why don't you guys try mind melt see if
you guys can go to the same page
like an improv exercise yeah it's like
you go like you count to three you go
one two three and you try to say the
same thing at the same time and then on
the next round you take what those two
things have in common and you try to say
the same thing okay no no YouTube what
the [ __ ]
this guy's always wrong
so think of a word and on the count of
three say the word that you're thinking
out loud okay and then at the count of
three after that think about what those
two words have in common and try to meld
your minds together okay okay ready okay
one two three penis
okay she said Annoying you said penis
okay
Venus now okay on three which is
annoying and B doesn't have in common
one
two three a boy
I was gonna say Alex
give it up for Alex and Emma okay
we absolutely learned nothing about Alex
I think we learned everything we need to
know
that is true everything we want to know
uh we got a man coming up named Colin
O'Meara
[Applause]
beautiful beautiful man go ahead Dave
when Giovanna
[Music]
gotta call it O'Meara
the pride of Philadelphia are you from
Philly
starting now
more YouTube on I'm good how are you
home I like that name I'll be honest I
don't think I've ever met with Yvonne
before well it's actually Giovanna oh
Hans
classic mistake
okay what is Jovana like what is where
is that for uh well so my father's
Sicilian and my mother
wanted something both from both worlds
or so they decided
so Sicily that's like that's like the
cool part right yes absolutely yeah
they're not Italians they're systems
right yeah have you seen as a brand yes
yeah yeah big fan I am welcome until he
died well yes
I'm on season five
well dude spoiler sorry
[Music]
is it accurate
um about sicilities
uh a little I mean I have a crowbar in
my trunk but okay
[Applause]
confused him to actually change my a
flat tire so yeah sure just because you
know this is being recorded it is a flat
tire what you call Mexicans
I changed the flat tires mine I love
that wow of all the dates you guys have
had the most chemistry Yeah well yeah
because I'm not a cop
yeah
several of my family members are are
they wow yeah it's likewise yeah
my dad's from Philly is he really wow so
are you an Eagles fan or well he is okay
yeah I'm like I don't know if it's
football where are you from
I was actually born in San Antonio oh
wow
sort of sort of a local native but yeah
so what brought Philly to San Antonio uh
the Army
um
yeah you ever go to a different country
yes Germany I think they're gonna fight
this is green
wow you're Sicilian and he looks like a
meatball so this works
Colin you asked Jovana what is Jovana
yeah it's kind of a direct question
yeah yeah like who are you like where
are you going uh are you that are you
are you religious or are you spiritual
one of them uh I was Easter yeah like
astrology stuff or like no no okay like
there's nothing out there that program
the world to work a certain way program
like simulation [ __ ] hey this is the
Matrix
well no you said you're a sicilian and
what was the other half a majority
I really don't uh I'm still single
um
hell yeah so it's Colin right yeah yeah
well yeah that's that's why it's amazing
show yeah I don't know why I guess
would you this was I I enjoyed watching
you guys hang out would you guys do this
elsewhere like would you go get coffee
and I don't drink coffee but I go yeah
wait what are we I'm sorry what are you
are eating I'm Irish Irish breakfast so
twists yeah yeah it is actually yeah oh
well you know as well I like a good
Southern you know uh old southern movie
yeah this is what happens to an Irishman
in Texas they turn Italian
so uh would you say that you're more uh
there's your spirituality is more in
line with uh the Salvadorian part
because I know that it doesn't seem very
Catholic the way it is Sicilians are oh
oh yeah no we both were catholic yeah
they're very uh hell yeah yeah very very
Catholic that's probably why you deviate
away from them oh I started to just like
God
religion right no I I mean
like organized religion yes yeah well
there's nothing organized about calling
them here besides his hair I'll have you
know but I actually did laundry today
and this the hair just did this hair
actually looked like it took effort I
swear to God didn't wake up like this
like he might have a robotic in his hair
than I do it definitely does he cares
about his hair a lot I mean I cut it and
I triple the back of it but the front
looks like that's why I'm just too lazy
to cut the back so I just let it go
business up front party in the back yeah
I gotta let him know you know it's Texas
after all
and Jovana
um what uh what's your have you ever
dated an Irishman
uh yes yeah how'd that go
it went okay but we I was in the
military so oh
I was in the military what branch Air
Force yes why yeah I'm just getting
together
you did say the universe was programmed
that's true oh yeah yeah well I was a
broadcaster so is that like Good morning
Vietnam type stuff yeah actually correct
wow yeah
[Music]
[Music]
could you give us an example of
something that you said on your
broadcast
uh well that's a child
well I can actually say um I was once
asked by a
Pakistani man does she belong to you
yeah and I was in uniform and I was like
uh I'm standing right here no no I
belong to myself but I was being
escorted by another uh male officer
[Music]
this is something you said on your
broadcast
no no I wasn't recording that or if I
did I think I erased it so you were just
doing a live podcast from war zones
welcome to this
this was actually a fun U.S program so
but yeah uh in Okinawa I actually
radioed the deviation the station there
so afn and it wasn't really you know
like what you imagined like Good Morning
America you know or Vietnam and you know
nothing like that it was here's a
playlist here's some American music the
entire Island enjoy so what was your
favorite music to play
uh actually like
I would say classic rock classic rock
yeah I'm actually older than I would
like
well look
okay
um
it's okay when you do it it's it's not
racist so you said that you're you're a
little or what have you ever dated I
mean how old are you like [ __ ] one
like I'm 23 22 but a puppy you don't
have to tell us how old you are not that
it's have you ever dated someone that
young no would you when I was that young
yes well would you ever would you ever
give a guy like that a chance
no if it's any consolation I always fade
older I mean
you always date older yeah I was gonna
throw my 18 year old daughter under the
bus oh my God oh my God is she here no
we're here
wow oh she's actually getting ready to
go into the air force oh my God
wow so you wouldn't date a 23 year old
what would you give them along basic
training
I'm beyond that point I want somebody to
show me something new
today
can't teach an old dog new tricks but a
young woman
wait what I don't know
I'm dangerously high right now
yeah bring more alcohol well why don't
you get it why don't you guys go to the
barn you get her a drink called yeah
yeah and it's gonna be had a lone star
okay they got a great Lone Star here
isn't it oh this is my first time well
one of three times I've been to Austin
oh wow we'll bring you through this time
uh that decision
wow bad suspicious I was I was thinking
oh I'll try something new come out with
some friends you know take a break from
nursing school and no nursing school
so why is it a bad decision to come down
here I think I was actually going to get
called up here on stage oh you're doing
great yeah this is fantastic you're
doing so much better than coming
well call like you're a great you're a
great guy
yeah yeah like I were
years younger yeah yeah for sure I won't
say how many years younger but if I were
years younger yeah it was a great boy
yeah whoa what the hell oh man
well say it like you need it
I'm terrible
whoa a real boy yeah
[Applause]
she's gonna put the drill and drill
sergeant on you I'm just gonna tag you
know
so Colin what's the what's your dating
life like you've dated a lot of older
women you said yeah it just kind of
happens that way I don't know
[Music]
I'm a big strong man
what's the most manliest thing that
you've done recently I uh [ __ ] I work
for a moving company
so I
use my body I get a blue collar I got a
very underemployed young man yeah that's
what a man says I'm a use my body
sounds like you used it too much yeah
I don't know but um where'd you get
those Rings uh they're just family rooms
a sandwich family and this is like
inheritance or whatever you know that's
your inheritance yeah
Goodfellas
[Music]
yeah I don't know I just I couldn't get
into it so was it all the just reminded
you at home or something
yes home with a military father yeah
very but your dad was in the military
too yeah president yeah my grandmother
and your grandfather and my oldest
brother wow it doesn't matter but yeah
three of my uncles
no no uh they were all learned oh yeah
artificial way to go Air Force is a
country club of the Armed Forces that's
what I'm saying right yeah sure some
jobs most jobs you know so Broadband
yes everybody thinks it's air
conditioned and then fun times
no there's no air conditioning not in
some places so you're just broadcasting
of the thick of it some people
what's uh what's like the craziest piece
of news you did you announce the Towers
falling or no I was not in the military
yet where were you I was in Germany okay
that's a good alibi
OT Miami I just graduated
what do you think about 911 conspiracy
theories
as I mean is it really conspiracy if you
see a plane fly into a building I mean
well what picture do you want
there's a lot of different ones but uh I
didn't even know it actually had to
happen until I left work got home and
everybody's glued to the TV and like
like what's going on somebody hit the
towers I was so young I was like what
towers yeah yeah yeah it was tragic yeah
somebody had hit the towers but a
missile hit the Pentagon anyways
you should have broadcast that I would
have had I've been trained well it was
here what yeah do us a little broadcast
of uh breaking the news of 9 11. go for
it
uh we're receiving reports that two
planes have hit the towers we've got
unconfirmed awesome why are you getting
a hard-on
multiple that's that's strange
well you guys have real good chemistry
you guys have good energy a little
sexual tension yeah
well yeah so he's just I'll wait for you
but do you have do you have a daughter
do you have a son no no would you like
one
Ramana
[Music]
he invited us to take off give it up for
Ian you can check him out online
six nine and I have a podcast out called
Bean Ian it's a real good time I think
you guys would enjoy it thank you so
much for having me give it up your heart
it's a great show thanks for coming up
man I hope one of you guys come up here
and also shout out to love for anyone to
celebrate that's Rosh Hashanah I got it
it's a New York holiday
we got Kyle Doty coming up
what other days when Taylor yeah
foreign
[Music]
a cow here often
um no never been here oh [ __ ]
no are you from Austin no I'm from
Arkansas Arkansas okay I have no idea
well you're with the Arkansas people yes
why are you there
um
just hanging out with friends you're
right I mean you're a bit of Ohio
North Carolina uh you've been in
California yeah same what part uh South
South by there yeah
how long have you guys been down for uh
until tomorrow instead of tomorrow all
right we're gonna add you have a good
time or you have barbecue no they did
what fun did you do uh we did mushrooms
last night oh me too
how much
um
give it up for a Taylor app and call it
or uh Kyle Jody
Kyle dirty
that's fun you guys all did mushrooms
together that's a lot of mushrooms where
did you get where did you guys Source
these mushrooms from your uh from your
friend Lindsay r
now a friend of a friend
secretive what's her name where do they
live not my friend
Kyle you uh went through a geographic uh
tour of America Ohio was mentioned
California
yeah I don't know how to get to know
people so my parents
it's just fitting information at them
until they find something to do with it
what's your favorite state Taylor my
favorite state yeah
um besides being high on mushrooms
state of mind I'm in Colorado I love
Arkansas but
you got any uh info for Colorado you
could spit out it's cold there it's cold
it's not it's not sometimes it is
I know it snows there do you wire them
it's not as cold as hell yeah don't go
after my boy Kyle Doty yeah yeah we're
so Valencia knows how to say my last
name right
he's definitely excited right
well you know they do have a lot of ski
and Resorts there you know you can't
have a ski resort unless it's cold yeah
uh Taylor what do you do for a work at
work
um
[Music]
earlier the great one and then I own a
diner is that also in a truck
a restaurant a real a real life
you work in one restaurant and one truck
yeah that's fun what made you get
started with the crate truck
um I got a finance degree and I didn't
want to work with Finance yet so so you
wanted to throw the money away that's
what I would do if I don't work in
finance anymore but like I'm making
small pancakes
that's the opposite of Finance
that's weird that's good it's fun Kyle
what do you do for a living I work in
restaurants
yeah but like I worked I do the dirty
work what do you do I serve thanks yeah
as a standard it's fine
what kind of restaurant it sucks uh well
we're gonna now it's a five star fajita
restaurant yeah
well I mean there's other stuff not
Mexican yeah well we don't call them
that anymore
[Music]
in Texas right now you live here cool up
here right now you live in Ohio no no I
live in Texas
[Music]
[Music]
you guys both did mushrooms at the same
time we did it was meant to be what'd
you see
thank you
I saw an alligator that's it oh there's
a bunch of coyotes last night we were
trying to sleep and they were circling
our tents and Howling that's uh
yeah I bet you slept really well no no
no no it seems kind of hard to hear yeah
it sucked yeah yeah I don't think
mushrooms outside right now are you uh
are you into guys that camp
what's your favorite place to camp at
camping so you guys did mushrooms what
did you see did you see anything I was
kind of kidding but we just went to a
concert and I didn't take a lot I'm a
baby what what concert
[Music]
[Music]
everything's new yeah
and uh yeah so you work camping how long
were you guys camping for uh I got there
Friday at like midnight and we left this
morning so like two and a half like two
days wow you guys are fresh off the
camping trip yeah what'd you do anything
did you guys
uh I got really tan
um almost got killed by Coyotes did you
see any coyotes no I heard them oh no
yeah yeah so were they bringing Mexicans
over were they the animals yeah
there it is the Mexicans uh
so we joke here in Texas uh just a
casual dehumanization
so how's Arkansas you guys get a lot of
coyotes there uh we've got these I don't
know if I would say a lot but they're
around
have you ever tried singing to them
you haven't done enough mushrooms yeah
that's fine anything right now I'm not a
singer yeah
[Music]
there's only two chairs in your middle
school
that's all right
Kyle what did you sing to the coyotes
can you give us an example of your
coyote call
I honestly I got my car and honked the
horn
I freaked out
that's what Paula was awesome that's
East Austin for you
that's fun coyotes uh so yeah you got
how long are you guys here for you guys
think you might go on another date
another date yeah
[Music]
um
what show
a comedian
David's house you're going to see Ian
Finance up there he's one of his openers
oh really got a little sneak peek yeah
anyways I won't be there
I'm just chilling Kyle you uh you wanna
maybe try to work your way into this
show right now
it doesn't make any sense
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Mel
[Music]
I'm sure you'll be here any minute now
we can't see anything up here yeah
imagine how I feel okay
[Music]
here he comes Sean
the Sean vibes
[Music]
Douglas Ellen
comedian
and single mantle Brian Day with Mel a
single female
foreign
how are you today I'm very good how are
you
yeah I've never gone on a date on a seat
this is my first time too
yes ma'am I'm gonna try it okay but no
dates on the same no dates on the stage
not getting it either not often yes
ma'am okay no don't call me ma'am I'm
waiting for them from Charleston South
Carolina
where are you uh from I'm actually from
Ohio okay
Cleveland summer but I've been here for
like 12 years okay you know more about
other things yeah I said I've been here
two years it's brand new wow you've been
here like three pillows hey yeah in the
middle of all that when all the Homeless
was going crazy
no you don't I really don't traffic's
really bad I've started to see parts of
town that are like all right that are
okay I'm sorry Charles Charleston okay I
have been there that is a nice place do
you want to go back
if comedy I gotta try okay that's what
the economy scene out here is like just
blowing up easily but uh back in
Charleston there's nothing that's what I
gave tours out there
because if you hate something that much
it's such a bad City I don't
it's good to have you though even though
you hate us so much you think traffic is
bad here it's awful there's nothing I
give tours
I think I like it Charleston is like two
two cars it's really it's either Uber is
a petty cat
um Mel you asked a lot of questions okay
is that good or bad very good very
polite you know you scared me I called
you Mano yeah
[Music]
yeah she wants someone old and wrinkly
face of a testicle
Mel what do you think about Doug he's
like very opinionated I mean nice but I
mean I'm sad that you don't like Austin
I love it here so I come here after all
the craziness happened the city's like
it's going through a lot of change and
obviously in your defense too like
during coven it done anywhere kind of
like it's a weird time it's depends so I
hope you give it a chance because it's
like Austin sucks everyone's dying of
Covenant
that was the pandemic Doug
uh Mel how long have you lived in Austin
like 12 10 or 12 years ish I think okay
yeah that's a long time yeah and you're
not even offended you don't have any
Hometown parade well I mean I'm not
originally from here so yeah
so if you had to defend Austin to this
Grouch this grumpy old man with the
rescued beer
how would you defend it you know maybe a
little ladybird lake is open well I
would say maybe like Travis over
ladybird Lake
[Music]
you
can pull your money together and get a
canoe
but people are doing that like kayak
thing I noticed this summer because like
kayak parties on Town Lake have you seen
this yeah have you done it no okay way
too late to do that this is my idea of
dating so I was like you guys are
hitting it off
I brought you here to [ __ ] block
just an example
um
but I mean breweries the East side's fun
that's where he lives he pays 500 in
rents you know on these I think thirteen
hundred dollars holy [ __ ] I hate it in
Austin honestly I was kind of actually
reasonable
[Music]
Daddy are you looking for a roommate
I don't know
I have a mortgage
I'm hoping on Tuesday for Asia for like
six weeks what part of Asia Bali and
Thailand I've been to Thailand Cambodia
okay well then maybe I won't be here
what part are you flying in Bangkok
Singapore Singapore
um
that's great I'm watching two white
people talk about Asia and this guy
knows nothing I'll pick your brain and
not the Asians
I've been I've been around them
if you want to know about Seattle
or not yeah that's good yeah
about uh 10 years
what's the Chinese right there it's like
a street it's a China street
but uh that's that's our time we gotta
head today
thank you guys so much for coming out
tonight
foreign
[Music]